[Musique]
Et maintenant, retrouvons une nouvelle
histoire de Papi Grenier.
Papi, papi, grenier, papi papi. Oh ! Oh
! Les enfants ! Oh, vous vous sentez
encore plus mauvais que d'habitude, dis
donc. Papi, papi, tu nous racontes une
histoire ? Ah, une histoire ? Est-ce que
je vous ai raconté la fois où j'étais
gardien dans un asile de moche ? Ah non,
pas celle-là. Ah ! Euh, alors est-ce que
je vous ai raconté la fois où j'étais
euh membre d'une unité d'élite ? C'était
en 1996. On s'appelait les Stars. On
devait nettoyer un manoir et j'étais
accompagné de toute mon équipe. Des
vrais
professionnels. Barry Burton. Je je suis
Chris Redfield. [ __ ]
[Musique]
Gill àel
de j'y tiens.
Albert Wesker.
Ça vous des
freeze Chris ? Mais non, ça c'est un
arbre
[ __ ] Resident Evil,
je me souviens maître dit que cette
histoire commençait mal. Il faisait
nuit, il y avait du brouillard. C'était
la pleine lune le soir d'Halloween dans
une allée bisextile. On venait d'être
poursuivi par des chiens mutants dans un
ancien cimetière indien. Le pilote
d'hélico nous avait laissé tomber en
nous faisant un doigt d'honneur et là
nous sommes arrivés dans un manoir
abandonné. Puis on entendit un coup de
feu
et là ben on a fait ce que tout être
humain aurait fait. Une soirée sandwich.
Attends. Non je me trompe. Paris tienu
ce bruit. Je suis Chris Redfield. Bon on
fait quoi ? Séparons-nous. Ça me semble
être la meilleure idée. Euh il y a un
cadavre de zombies par terre.
Camouflons-nous avec du sang frais. Ça
me semble être la meilleure idée. Papi,
dis la vérité, c'est pas possible qu'il
soit aussi nul.
Cher journal, aujourd'hui, je suis
arrivé dans un manoir qui fait très très
peur. Ça me donne des cheveux blancs.
On était tous très nuls. Bref, pendant
ce temps-là, j'étais parti avec Gill
pour explorer le manoir. C'était pas
facile parce qu'on voyait souvent rien
du tout. On avait un peu de mal à voir
ce qui était devant nous avec les angles
des murs bizarrement.
Oh de sandwich quoi ? Il y a rien du
tout là. Attends, je vois pas du tout le
[Musique]
Non, on est mieux ici en fait. Le manoir
était envahi de zombies. Il sentaient
mauvais. Il traînaient leurs pieds
partout. Heureusement, notre capitaine
était un expert et il savait comment
réagir.
Ne bougez plus d'un cheveux. Leur acuité
visuelle est basée sur le mouvement.
Ah c'est bon, je casse. Ouais, moi
aussi.
C'était un boulot dangereux quand même
de se balader dans le manoir. Il y avait
pas que les zombies, il y avait un
serpent géant, il y avait des corbeaux,
il y avait un monstre avec des
tentacules
géantes. On fait quoi maintenant ? Il y
a qu'une solution contre monstre comme
ça.
On se casse.
J'ai dit on se casse.
Ah papi, tu es dégueulasse. Oh oui,
pardon. En même temps, on éétait pas
équipé contre ce genre de monstre. On
avait aucune arme. On était nous-même
obligé de chercher nos propres armes
dans le manoir. Ah, ce manoir, c'était
un vrai labyrinthe. Je compte pas le
nombre d'aller-retours que je faisais
dedans. Imagine les gens qui vivaient là
quand ils voulaient aller au chiotte,
quoi. Ça devait être horrible.
Tu dois traverser tout le manoir pour
aller jusqu'à la pièce secrète qui
s'ouvre seulement quand tu as trouvé la
clé cachée dans la statue qui te donne
la partition pour jouer la mélodie sur
le piano qui ouvre la pièce secrète pour
trouver l'émerode bleue que tu dois
placer dans l'œil gauche de la statue du
sous-sol qui ouvre la porte des WC. Tu
fais quoi ? Je pisse dehors. Enfin bref,
moi j'étais retourné à l'entrée du
manoir mais Wesker avait disparu.
Quelque chose me disait qu'il y avait
peut-être un traître parmi nous. Mais
qui ?
[Musique]
La survie dans ce manoir, c'était pas
quelque chose de facile hein pour
trouver de l'équipement au fouiller
partout. Surtout que bon, je dois vous
avouer qu'on était pas hyper bien
organisé niveau optimisation de
l'espace. Bon sang, je ne peux pas
prendre ce chargeur. J'ai déjà ces trois
clés sur moi. Heureusement, ce qui nous
sauvait, c'est que même quand ça
chauffait pour nous, les zombies étaient
pas très futés. Gill, attention derrière
[Musique]
toi. Oh !
Prends ton
[Musique]
temps. Ah là là, ces zombies hein ? Il y
a que deux choses qui pouvaient les
arrêter. Cinq balles dans la tête ou une
porte en bois.
[Musique]
Mais des fois quand même ça nous
arrivait d'être blessé et quand ça
arrivait, il fallait qu'on trouve
nous-même de quoi faire passer la
douleur. Il y avait de l'herbe partout
dans cette maison. C'était incroyable.
C'était bien utile quand même. Ah, il
m'a mordu. Tiens, prendre de l'herbe.
Ah, je suis tombé dans un piège. Tu vis
prendre de l'herbe ? Aï ! J'ai très mal
papi. Comment ça s'est terminé
finalement ? Oh ben déjà pour commencer
maintenant je déteste les chiens. Ah !
Oh ! Nom de Dieu ! Et ensuite ben
finalement à la fin j'ai dû affronter un
monstre géant et j'ai découvert que le
pilote de l'hélicoptère me
détestait. J'ai un bazooka, je lui
lance.
Non, laisse-la galérer encore un peu. Et
finalement, on a réussi à
[Musique]
s'échapper. Cher journal, quel dommage
qu'on ait pas réussi à sauver Chris. Je
suis là, [ __ ] Heureusement que
c'était fini parce que j'en avais plus
qu'assé de ce manoir rembl de tous ces
zombies horribles et moche et puis il y
avait leur dreadlocks et leur musique
insupportable qui me cassait les
oreilles. Et puis mais papi, les zombies
ça fait pas de musique quoi. Et sur quoi
je tirai alors moi ? Le manoir était
envahi de zombies. Il sentaient mauvais.
Il traînaient leurs pieds partout. Il y
avait de l'herbe partout dans cette
maison.
[Musique]
E mec, tu as pas du feu ?
E viens faire un bisou mec.
Oh tant pis, au moins j'aurais appris
une bonne recette de sandwich. Papi,
papi, tu nous racontes une autre
histoire ? Oh, bien sûr, mais ça sera
pour une prochaine fois.